[Musique]
la question est à poser dans quel état
se trouve-t-elle notre télévision
c'était à une époque où la télévision
avait besoin d'un grand changement les
coûts de production des émissions
originales explosaient et la soif du
public pour ses émissions était elle
aussi en augmentation regardez-vous par
jour la télévision à peu près 50
on était alors mur pour la télévision
payante
mais c'est après huit ans d'audience des
querelles fédérales provinciales encore
une fois que le CRTC accorde une
trentaine de permis dont le plus
important celui de premier choix une
firme de Toronto Québec a donc décidé de
poser ses propres conditions pour la
télé payante en plus de celle déjà posée
par le CRTC allons-nous assister à une
nouvelle bataille de juridiction entre
le Québec et le gouvernement fédéral
j'espère que non plutôt que d'avoir des
Canadiens qui s'abonnerait un réseau
purement américain et qui financerait
les meilleurs aux États-Unis qui nous a
semblé qui était urgent d'avoir un
système bien canadien
que la télévision payante va parler
français au Québec une bonne partie de
la population souhaite voir des versions
françaises de films américains c'est de
la présentation en primeur de Thaïlande
au cours de ces négociations tous les
grands joueurs veulent prendre leur
place dans un marché très lucratif
premier choix envisage même de présenter
des films érotiques et aussi des
productions américaines du type Playboy
pourquoi les gens perdent-ils pour voir
de la télévision payante si ce n'est
pour voir quelque chose qui n'est pas
présenté ailleurs le CRTC a d'abord
voulu éviter l'invasion des productions
américaines il accorde donc dans la
foulée a permis de diffusion à une ferme
québécoise cette fois Québec qui
souhaite présenter un contenu semblable
à celui de premier choix il faut dire
que c'est surtout des films surtout des
films récents populaires
personne ont déjà le décodeur et la
distribution massive de ces appareils
faciles à installer par l'usager
commencera demain il y a eu ensuite une
multitude de chaînes spécialisées qui
sont venues révolutionner l'univers de
la télévision peut-être trop pour
certains si on est plus de choix ça va
coûter encore plus cher c'est ça qui
m'achète un petit peu il y en a déjà
beaucoup peut-être même trop
ou passé c'est selon mais la
transformation dans l'industrie de
l'audiovisuel semble loin d'être terminé
40 ans après l'arrivée des chaînes
payantes
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada MONT